bonjour nous tous bonjour federica
bonjour j me et bonjour jean claude
duverger
bonjour la table et ceux qui nous
écoutent
alors vous êtes conseiller territorial à
l'assemblée de martigues vous êtes porte
parole du groupe
ep mn au sein de cette assemblée et nous
allons commencer par ses passes il faut
dire la polémique du moment en tout cas
le contentieux politiciens au moins du
moment l'espace culturel camille
darsières qui se trouve dans l'ancien
palais de justice à fort de france
un bâtiment qui est propriété de la ctn
et le président du conseil exécutif de
la ctm donc alfred marie-jeanne avec sa
majorité veulent s'y implanter un musée
d'art contemporain et ils souhaitent ils
réclament même vivement pour ainsi dire
que les lieux soient librement
accessibles en vue d'une mission d'
expertise pour la réalisation de ce
musée d'art contemporain et voilà que le
maire de fort de france veut attaquer
cette action en justice
jean claude duverger alors qu'est ce que
l'homme politique mais aussi l'homme de
culture que vous êtes dit de cette
affaire-là
eh bien j'ai bu était à venir lors d'une
plénière sur cette affaire mais qui est
mort qui n'a pas de sens sinon est
habité par une méchanceté gratuite une
mais chassez politicienne qui n'a aucun
sens d'ailleurs je n'ai dit il y est il
est prévu par la ville de fort de france
depuis quoiqu'il y ait un espace d'art
culturel avec la littérature de la
caraïbe et à l'intérieur qu'il y ait un
centre d'art contemporain
on a tous parlé il nous ne sommes pas
contre qu'il y ait un musée d'art
contemporain au contraire comme c'est
dans le projet de la ville
alors qu'est ce qui fait problème je
suis hébergé le problème c'est que vous
devriez vous rejoindre là tout le monde
est d'accord mais tout le monde est
d'accord pour avoir un sens d'après
palais de justice
ça veut dire que c'était diminué quelque
chose comme ça a toujours été une
tentative au comportement général vous
rappeler le cette histoire de 17 hier de
l'aéroport en vélo non celle cher
donnait famille ici est donné il ya
toujours eu un comportement comme ça que
l'on comprend pas et certains voudraient
dire que c'est le comportement politique
ça n'a rien de la politique sinon c'est
de la méchanceté et alors où est le
propriétaire
bâtiment il fait ce qu'il veut tout
d'abord il n'est pas beaucoup mieux qu'à
propriétaire parce que kamel c'est vrai
qu'à une convention en soit la ville la
veillée et l'a6 et l'a7 et élite 1 et
l'état veut dire que la ville quand même
à céder une partie le palais de justice
qu actuelle et sous un terrain de la
ville
mais ce n'est pas sale pauvre s'il
fallait faire un musée un centre d'art
contemporain d'abonnés que c'est intégré
dans un projet plus global de la ville
il appartiendra à la ctm d'aider la
ville il a pas au diète appartient de la
ctm d'aidé à cette réalisation
mais c'est maintenant la ctm est dans
une espèce de concurrence qui a toujours
eu lieu pour vous la ctm veut faire son
musée sont mus éliminé attaqué la ville
de toutes parts était l'ex maternité
s'est-elle tcsp
ça pourrait encore on a eu votre analyse
donc ça va aller sur le terrain
judiciaire on va pas trop longtemps
épiloguer sur ce cas précis mais vous
l'avez dit on a l'impression que c'est
une énième polémique où je dirais les
intérêts partisans peut-être pourrait
l'emporter sur l'intérêt général alors
vous avez évoqué effectivement l'épisode
du lycée schoelcher l'épisode où on
pense aux transports évidemment le
transport en commun sur la cacem avec
martinique transport et puis voilà que
maintenant la culture l'art se se trouve
peut-être presque otage de belles
rivalités politiciennes entre un corps
et un l'autre parce que on comprend bien
que cepn mène peut-être contre grands
ensembles et pumba payant chance et je
n'ai pas ça l'est pas
je n'ai pas pnm go sable et c'est la
ville de fort de france d'abord contre
une petite équipe une méfiance c'est pas
ce même déjà dans l'esprit de beaucoup
ville de fort-de-france et galeux ppm
peut-être mais pourquoi je le dis c'est
pas grâce un blé parce que je n'ai pas
l'impression que tout le monde à grains
semblait était d'accord la première
intervention a été l'intervention de
nelu d'une élue du grand ensemble et qui
dit mais on pourrait le faire ailleurs
pourquoi pas ailleurs pourquoi là il ya
des activités
je ne sais pas en fin de vacances il y
avait beaucoup d'activité mais je veux
dire quand je dis ce comportement si on
continue on va penser que je suis
uniquement
elle me pose un nom je voudrais que les
gens réfléchissent il ya un problème
sous le pont neuf
la première réaction c'était à qui la
faute ce n'était pas ça c'était comment
sont des commerçants quelles difficultés
comment va se se prendre qu'est-ce qu'on
va fait pour régler un problème aux
prêcheurs le premier premier la première
réaction oui mais c'est que le conseil
général qui était la régionale avait
passé convention avec l'état c'est ce
n'est pas ça le problème
est-ce qu'on peut aider les gens qui
sont là il n'y a pas une préoccupation
pour le développement et pour la
martinique
jean claude duverger le parti
progressiste martiniquais est en plein
prépare une autre partie évidemment en
pleins préparatifs des municipales alors
des décisions ont déjà été prises on
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la commission d'investitures justement
des des candidatures pour les élections
municipales alors évidemment toute
logique vos maires sortants ont été
désignés 1 pour être oui didier laguerre
à fort de france marie thérèse casimir
youth à basse pointe jean claude et
qu'en ville au carbet et felix 6 mai à
bellefontaine ça y est ils ont ils ont
l'investiture de du ppm et puis alors il
ya deux 2 autres qui ont obtenu
l'investiture
c'est peut-être là un peu plus des
surprises emmanuel granier au gros morne
et edson gêne à case-pilote alors
rapidement emmanuel grenier au
gros-morne pourquoi il était plutôt
connu comme étant plutôt sur la droite
de l'échiquier politique martiniquais
voilà qui l'a label ppm au gros morne
pour les municipales prochaine c'est
peut-être ça qui va à l'essai qui va
faire comprendre pourquoi nous faisons
campagne
des fois nous faisons campagne pour que
ceux qui ne sont pas avec nous
aujourd'hui soit avec nous deux mais
ceux qui comprennent au travail m'a fait
manuel granet s'est présenté déjà aux
gones il y à un moment où il a désavoué
au comportement que ce qu'il pensait
être avec lui et il a hélas vu le
travail réalisé par le
simple une martinique nouvelle le parti
progressiste martiniquais et a voulu
adhérer
maintenant on n'a pas d'autre on n'a pas
d'autre candidat pour des pots qu'on a
choisi un candidat candidat qui inscrit
au ppm qui veut se présenter le soutien
je crois qui est manuel granier la ligue
il est encarté tacchelli oui ok être
sont nos jeunes à case-pilote cmc 1
jeunes d'ailleurs qu'ils enquêtaient
avec le met en place il faut savoir moi
ça me rappelle un peu la période où
comme ils s'appellent mouriès est venu
avec nous parce qu'il avait mal supporté
qu'on traite ses airs quand de macau
d'excéder raid était venu avec nous ils
étaient des hommes et du quart bill
perry elle sonne gênes a laissé le camp
de ralph font plaisir pour ainsi dire
d'ailleurs il est un de ses adjoints il
fait partie de la majorité municipale
devra font plaisir à case-pilote et l'a
donc vous vous le présenter certainement
contreras le plaisir qu'ils ont
l'intention de le présenter et analyser
la structure de base du parti qui lui a
proposé avec un président est requis à
proposer une candidature
le concept est validé par la direction
du pp validé par la db m après une
rencontre avec la commission
d'investiture qui a posé les questions
nécessaires à être posée et nous reste
peu de temps louis marie sainte à votre
soutien pour l'élection municipale à
ducos et puis au sein de l'alliance
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
vous avez déjà décidé d'apporter votre
entier soutien à david zobda évidemment
lamentin donc il était élu maire n'y a
pas longtemps il a pris la suite de dans
la mandature de pierre samot et puis
alain claude lagier en toute logique du
mouvement populaire franciscain au
françois
pour le reste des candidatures le pmn
alliance ça va peut-être difficile
pourquoi on ne voit pas le nom par
exemple de jenny dulys bon vous étiez à
la fête patronale iront dans le rouge
je vous ai croisé enfin voilà jenny
dulys par exemple n'est pas la citer
d'autres non non non on pourrait citer
d'autres mais un vase soutenait jenny
dulys mais on a on a respecté les autres
partis quand les autres partis un
souhaitait même ceux qui a déjà qui
souhaite qu'il y ait une réunion avec
nos symboles de ne pas être présenté
xceed x ou y
2 de l'urd un autre mail jénine et du
lis tout ce qu'ils vont nous demander
notre soutien qui serait le pnm pour
l'autre soutiennent il faut qu'ils
fassent d'abord la demande c'est simple
c'est mais il via ailier a même déjà
qu'ils soient jeunes qui disent que je
vais l réquisitionné pas des gens
veulent aller a pas âme et à leur
drapeau de leur poche me disant je
ferais rassemblement général donc je
veux pas qu'il y ait telle ou telle
couleur sur ma candidature
jean claude duverger le ppm qui a
également comment dirais-je rédigeant
communiqué de presse à propos de la
situation concernant la violence et les
armes chez nous en martinique
là il y a d une intersyndicale de la
police nationale qui vient de rencontrer
le président de l'assemblée vous faites
partie du bureau de l'assemblée vous
n'êtes pas vice-président mais vous êtes
très proche de claude lise on sait que
donc voilà et donc il est proposé qu'ils
interviennent lors de la prochaine
séance plénière donc de l'assemblée de
martinique
comment vous voyez tout ça vous êtes
d'accord et puis donc voilà il s'agit de
réclamer des moyens à l'état quoi dire
vous voyez la situation est devenue il
ya eu une proposition du président alice
mans va rapidement tous avaient une
proposition du président lise qu'il y
ait une réunion pour rencontrer
l'intersyndicale et j'ai demandé aux
membres de pnm tous ceux qui étaient
disponibles c'était un peu une période
où retraite va tous nous étions 11 à
cette réunion donc on a rencontré
lorsque nous nous étions tous là on est
absolument d'accord d'ailleurs sur la
circulation d'armes ce n'est pas la
première fois ya quelques années je
rencontrais des douaniers qui me disait
ne pas avoir suffisamment de moyens pour
était à venir au marais pour aller voir
le dernier bateau il faut réclamer des
moyens alors vous vous réclamez la mise
en oeuvre d'un plan d'action
opérationnel et spécifique de manière
urgente
il faut retenir la l'urgence après le
geste parce qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment
il y avait beaucoup plus de personnes et
beaucoup plus d'armes dans la rue que
des âmes dans la police ou de la
gendarmerie parce qu'il nous faut
traiter cela mais cela ne peut pas se
traiter uniquement par la police secrète
aussi avec la douane et puis en dehors
de cela c'est une responsabilité qui
relève de tout le monde c'est d'aider
des jeunes des hommes de la maison et
des parents ne disent pas ti les âmes là
on n'a rien fait si à l'école on
commence par y adopte jeu c'est un début
il ya une urgence là maintenant c'est
que le gouvernement tienne compte de la
réalité
il y à une réalité est moche quoi un
policier pour 241 sony cycle est par
ailleurs il y aurait un policier pour
cent soixante quinze 75
si j'ai bien compris du clos de moto
avec eux avec les syndicats qu'il y ait
une prise en compte de l'eau crise est
un cri merci jean claude duverger
d'avoir répondu à nos questions bonne
journée à vous toutes et à vous tous
bonne journée
[Musique]